hey this is pressure Locker this problem
involves 100 red balls 100 blue balls
and two urns you distribute all of the
balls between the two urns placing at
least one ball in each urn you then
select an urn at random and you select a
random ball from that urn you win $100
if you select a red ball what is your
best strategy for distributing the balls
and what is your best winning percentage
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution so here's the optimal strategy
in one of the urns you place one red
ball and none of the blue balls in the
other urn you place all of the remaining
balls 99 red balls and 100 blue balls
let's calculate the probability of
selecting a red ball from each urn from
the first urn there's only one red ball
so there's a hundred percent chance that
you will select a red ball in the other
urn there are 99 red balls divided by a
hundred and 99 balls in total so there's
a 99 divided by a hundred and 99 chance
of selecting a red ball from that urn
since you select an urn at random each
case is equally likely which means your
overall winning percentage is the
average of these two cases this results
in a winning percentage that's nearly 75
percent
it's approximately seventy four point
eight seven percent and this is quite
surprising you have a nearly three in
four chance of selecting a red ball this
intuitively seems like the best answer
but how do we know that let's prove the
optimality of the strategy there are two
cases to consider first imagine a
distribution of balls which places an
equal number of red and blue balls in
each urn there is a 50% chance of
selecting a red ball from each urn which
means there's an overall 50% chance of
selecting a red ball the success rate in
this strategy is worse than the strategy
we just described so any distribution of
this kind is not optimal so let's
consider the other case we'll imagine
that we have to place more red balls and
blue balls in one of the urns call that
urn a that means the other urn r&b must
have more blue balls than red balls B is
greater than or equal to R plus one
where B is the number of blue balls and
urn B and R is a number of red balls in
urn be
what's the probability of selecting a
red ball from earn B this is the number
of red balls divided by the total number
of balls in our B because we have a
lower bound on B this places an upper
bound on the fraction we substitute R
plus 1 as the lower bound on B we can
simplify this to be the fraction R
divided by 2r plus 1 if we take the
derivative of this function it is always
going to be positive in its domain this
means R divided by 2r plus 1 is
increasing in the variable R in other
words the more red balls we place in
earn B the higher the chances that we'll
select a red ball at most earn B has 99
red balls this is because we need to
save one red ball to place an RNA which
has more red balls than blue balls
so at most this fraction R divided by 2
R plus 1 can have a value of 99 divided
by 199 this is the value if we
substitute R equals 99 so we know the
probability selecting a red ball from
earned B is at most 99 divided by 199
and naturally the probability of
selecting a red ball from earn a has to
be limited by a hundred percent because
our probability cannot be higher than
100%
we exactly achieve these upper bounds in
the strategy we exactly get the highest
probability of selecting a red ball from
each urn and therefore the strategy we
describe is optimal did you figure it
out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch me on my blog my near decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch around social
media app press collector and if you
liked the video please check out my
books there links in the video
description